Once upon a time, Mitt Romney
and his haircut tweeted
about president-elect
and popular Sunkist soda flavor
Donald Trump "Hitting on married
women? Condoning assault?
"Such vile degradations demean
our wives and daughters
and corrupt
America's face to the world."
But after a whirlwind bromance
where the pair talked about
the secretary of state job
while dining on-- I don't know--
probably frog legs
and bald eagle wings,
I don't know what they eat--
Romney said this to reporters.
He won the general election.
-Oh.
-GAROFALO: Oh.
What a cuck.
-(laughter)
-I'm impressed.
You couldn't actually see
Trump's lips moving
where he stuffed his hand
up Mitt's ass.
"I lost because it's official.
"Mr. Trump is a better person
than me, okay?
"I'm... I'm a big baby
who goes poopy in his diaper,
"and Trump is my daddy.
"What the (bleep)
do you people want from me?!
"I'm not enough of a monster?
"You want me to go out there
and grab a lady
"in the bathing suit area
while drunk on caffeine?!
I have no dignity left."
(laughter)
All right, so clearly, clearly,
Trump made Romney say all that,
so if he wants to become
secretary of state,
he has to say that. Comedians,
what are some other things
Mitt will have to admit
to join Trump's cabinet?
-Janeane.
-He will have to reveal
the Mormon who styles
his wigs and murkins.
-HARDWICK: Yes. Points.
-(laughter)
Michael Ian Black.
Uh, he'll have to say,
"My carefully cultivated image
"as an elder statesman
of the GOP
"was actually
a tinsel-thin veneer
"I was willing
to shove up my own asshole
in order to get a job
with a man I swore to oppose."
-All right, yeah. I think...
-(cheering, applause)
I mean, that's a paraphrasing,
but yes, points.